[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de si on parlait sport
aujourd'hui c'est une émission un peu
particulière car elle sera entièrement
consacrée à Paris Nice la fameuse course
cycliste ftera cette année sa 82e
édition et elle partira pour la 15e fois
consécutive depuis les Yvelines on vient
d'avoir la confirmation lors de la
conférence de presse c'est la ville des
Mureau qui va accueillir le départ 2024
le dimanche 3 mars et le lendemain le
peloton se lancera depuis la petite
commune de toiri événement exceptionnel
dispositif exceptionnel nous avons
délocalisé notre plateau spécialement
pour l'occasion la conférence vient tout
juste de se terminer avec côté sur ce
début d'émission Grégory canalé
journaliste de tb78 c'est une véritable
encyclopédie sur le parénis croyez-moi
bonjour greégoryi alors le petit micro
arrive voilà on doit se passer le micro
bonjour Michel alors vous allez nous
préparer une petite envolée sur
l'histoire d'amour entre les ivines et
le parénis c'est ça je vous parlerai de
cette histoire d'amour qui dure
puisqu'elle dure désormais depuis 2010
une grande histoire d'amour entre le
parinis et les ivelines nous avons juste
à côté Carl olive le conseiller
départemental qui nous fait l'honneur de
venir sur cette émission pendant une
dizaine de minutes environ alors Carl
c'est toujours un événement particulier
parénis oui parénis c'est le département
des Yvelines c'est c'est un beau roman
c'est une belle histoire et c'est une
romance qui date pas d'aujourd'hui
puisque vous l'avez rappelé ça date de
de 2010 mais c'est la continuité de ce
que souhaite le président du conseil
départemental Pierre Bédier et je me
félicite vraiment que à la fois la très
belle ville de toiri qui fait partie de
la 12e circonscription des ivelines et
été é chois tout comme celle de de mon
ami François gar au Mau qui est une
vraie cité sportive justement nous avons
avec nous les deux maires des deux
communes alors François gar maire des
Mureaux bonjour bonjour alors j'imagine
que vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui
écoutez je suis satisfait parce que à la
fois comme le disait Carl on est une
terre les ivelines de vélo je me
rappelle des boucles de la scène je me
rappelle de la Pol multiplié à
Chanteloup au Mureau en 1974 de Tour de
France était passé 50 après nous
retrouvons la lumière grâce à la Course
au Soleil François moutau vous êtes
juste à côté vous êtes le maire de toiri
vous aussi vous passez une très belle
journée aujourd'hui bah aujourd'hui
c'est un peu la consécration de notre
rôle
touristique de la France mais aussi des
Yvelines et le fait que Pierre
Bédier et ào choisi Toir nous satisfait
avec une circonstance nous avons autant
d'habitants que d'animaux dans les eau
et quelles sont justement vos premières
réactions
est-ce que vous aviez anticipé cette
grande
journée il se trouve qu'avec Chris
prudom tout à l'heure il y avait un faux
bruit qui disait que le Tour de France
passait à to à to Il a 2 ans et donc
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie c'est pas
une fake news c'est une vraieir
accueillera Paris Nice non c'est
effectivement pour tout le le village
une grande mise en valeur et nous sommes
très très contents et même si je
pratique plus de vélo depuis un certain
temps je trouve que c'est très
intéressant à la fois sur le plan
culturel mais aussi d'animation et donc
c'est une très bonne chose pour
l'ensemble du département et en
particulier François gar vous êtes une
plus grosse commune que to j'imagine que
vous êtes quand même tout autant ravi
d'accueillir le on est ravi justement
que le Conseil départemental et choisis
les Mureaux comme point de départ
d'autant plus que nous serons le point
de départ et je faire un petit clin
d'œil à l'activité économique des Mureau
nous avons un lanceur AR rien 5
maintenantien 6 et c'est nous qui allons
booster Paris oui vous êtes plus
seulement la Cité de l'espace en 2024
vous serez aussi la cité du vélo ben on
sera la cité bien évidemment de l'espace
mais on sera surtout la cité du vélo et
aussi 100 ans après parce qu'on avait eu
en 1924 les Jeux Olympiques à la voile
et nous sommes le seul site de 1924 qui
reste réellement donc venez au bord de
scène Carl olive c'est toujours on va
dire une tradition de choisir une grosse
commune desivine et une petite commune
des le lendemain oui puis je le disais
tout à l'heure vous avez raison c'est
aussi continuité de ce que nous mettons
en place avec les collègues du conseil
départemental autour de de notre
Président vous savez le plan vélo
quinquenal c'est 62 millions d'euros
pour les collectivités moi j'en suis
ravi parce que quand on discute avec
François moutau et la Belleville les les
les habitants toiri avec les mriotins
cher à François Garet il y a une vraie
belle valorisation de l'esprit sportif
en général et qui plus est avec ce
parinist vous ne pouvez pas imaginer la
valorisation du territoire tel qu'il est
conçu par ASO par par Christian prudom
par les réalisateurs et souvent quand on
va voir les les collègues maires ou les
collègues députés aujourd'hui dans le
bilan qu'ils font de leurs actions à
l'année souvent on a la la marque de
parinis ou du Tour de France car je
rappelle aussi que le département des
Yvelines est très attaché également à
faire en sorte qu'une étape du cours de
France Vienne ponctuer ou démarrer une
étape de la petite reine et comment le
département choisit ses communes il y a
un casting ça se passe comment oui
d'abord il y a beaucoup de de candidats
qui euh qui font appel à à projet puis
il y en a évidemment peu de sélectionnés
mais depuis maintenant 14 ans que ça
existe vous le disiez à juste titre cher
Monsieur c'est la 15e le 15e départ de
de parinis de la même manière que le le
Tour de France à son partenariat avec le
département des divines bien le
président Bédier la commission qui qui
l'entoure font en sorte que il y ait une
diversité dans les propositions qui sont
retenues et je trouve que le mariage
aujourd'hui jeallais dire entre entre un
village un des plus beau village avec
deux François c'est ça les frèes Françis
François c'est à la mode en ce moment je
parlais du pape François moutau et et
François Garet je vous le dis ça fait
très plaisir et surtout on notre prisme
c'est la porte d'entrée c'est livelinois
c'est l'administrer et on en parlait
avec François moutau mon ami de de Toir
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que pour les
habitants de toiri ça va être un moment
historique à non pas douter parce que je
me dis bien aussi que tu auras des clin
d'œils faits avec ce zoo international
et c'est historique hein pour vos deux
communes ce départ du parinice François
Garet ah benah écoutez c'est c'est
historique en plus je pense que c'est
une fierté pour la population surtout
qu'il y aura beaucoup de spectateurs qui
vont venir et aussi on profite de
parinis pour lancer une opération dès le
début janvier sur savoir rouler à vélo
et avec toute une opération sur la
sécurité routière où nos 23 écoles les
22 écoles publiques plus l'école privée
auront un champion cycliste qui sera
Parin pour pour apprendre à rouler à
vélo François moutau est-ce que vous
avez un petit peu parler avec vos
administrés de cette possibilité de
d'organiser de recevoir le par je viens
d'écouter François on a à toiri mis
depuis 10 ans en place le permis de
conduire le vélo avec les écoles
élémentaires et donc ça vient dans la
continuité donc c'est assez chouette les
chefs d'entreprise on les a réunis et on
va faire un concours de vitrine quelque
chose pour effectivement qu'il a bien
une enfin une une adhésion qui soit
montré de la population et pas seulement
affiché et vos administrés sont déjà au
courant ou vous aviez gardé le secret
jusqu'au dernier moment nous sommes
maires nous savons garder des secrets
dans la limite de la de garder le secret
qu je je fais un petit clinœ quand même
à à Toir toiri qui est vraiment une
ville sportive hein euh moi j'ai la
chance de participer à à la course du
worldwide euh de de Toir qui qui est
juste formidable qui aura lieu début
janvier à l'instar de ce que peut faire
François Garet mais vous savez je
regardz mes petit on cour à travers les
animaux c'est ça ENF ah oui oui c'est
formable et peut-être et peut-être que
les coureurs en tout cas je leur
souhaite puissent aussi appréhender ce
que c'est un un des plus beaux eau de de
France je regardais mes petites notes et
c'est pas simplement parinis et le Tour
de France je dirais le partenariat entre
le vélo et et l'histoire du département
puisqueavec ao on a les Championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste également on
a 5000 5000 licenciers et on a par
exemple une coupe de France qui aura
lieu à épone donc on voit bien qu'il y a
aussi un sens dans ce que nous
souhaitons donner dans dans l'engagement
qui est le aôre notamment sur quand je
parlais du plan vélo sur l'aménagement
des voies douces l'aménagement des des
pistes cyclables et c'est vrai que le
sport évidemment qui est un catalyseur
social transversal est en quelque sorte
la Seris sur le gâteau que nous offrons
à à tous les administrés voir oui
justement quel message on fait passer
quand on organise un Paris Nice ou
presque Eveline Nice finalement bah
pardon me le dire mais le Tour de France
comme parinit c'est la France le Tour de
France vous allez comme parinit vous
allez voir des petits des jeunes des
moyens vous allez voir des des chômeurs
des chefs d'entreprise et cetera le Tour
de France comme parénis c'est la France
et c'est la France positivement c'est la
France qu'on aime voilà et je pense que
c'est important de le dire parce que
quand on vient sur parinis ou quand on
vient sur le Tour de France on vient pas
faire la gueule on vient assister à un
magnifique rendez-vous de de sport et et
de et de cyclisme et c'est une grande
fête nationale telle qu'on aimerait en
vire plus plus souvent dans notre beau
pays dernière question avant de tous
vous libérer et passer à la deuxème
partie de de cette
émission François garé quel message vous
voulez faire passer à vos administrés en
organisant ce ce type d'événement très
rapidement ben déjà premièrement que les
Mureau est mise en lumière deuxièmement
le sport est un c'est quelque chose
d'important pour la règle parce que bien
évidemment il y a des coureurs il y a
des respects de règles avec des
commissaires des juges et cetera comme
en football il y a l'arbitre et je pense
que le troisième point aussi qui est
important c'est qu'aujourd'hui le sport
est un vecteur de paix un vecteur
d'unité et un vecteur d'harmonie et
notamment sur parinis qui a bien évolué
au niveau des concurrents maintenant il
y a des concurrents qui viennent de
presque tous les continents donc
franchement c'est universel et c'est
quelque chose aujourd'hui dans les temps
qui courent qu'on devrait retrouver un
peu partout dans le monde François
moutau le message que vous voulez faire
passer aux habitants de Toir aux
habitants de toiré mais aussi aux
habitants de la France je trouve que
parinis comme le Tour de France c'est un
bon moyen de découvrir notre pays
d'avoir toutes ces richesses il se
trouve que j'ai accompagné avec
l'Académie de gourmandise le Tour de
France pendant une qu d'anné mais je
pense que c'est pour moi la gourmandise
et le vélo c'est un peu la même chose
c'est la façon de vivre de vivre en
harmonie de vivre en harmonie avec notre
pays et que toari soit placé à ce
niveaau-là c'est sensationnel pour nous
merci à tous les tro d'avoir participé à
cette émission vous souhaite de de
belles choses pour cette organisation du
parinisme Merci à VOUS Carl olive d'être
passé également sur ce plateau on va
faire ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
sportif un changement car le liv va
sortir et les deux mères vont sortir on
va avoir Christian prudom et François Le
Marchand qui vont arriver sur ce plateau
François le marchand vous pouvez venir
et vous installer juste là Christian
prudom n'est pas très loin il va arriver
dans quelques instants il arrive je le
vois il tenez prenez le petit micro vous
allez vous mettre là ici à chom voilà là
non mettez-vous là on est à l'aise on
est ici on est au département
alors bonjour messieurs François Le
Marchand Christian prudom sont donc avec
nous sur ce plateau mais on va passer
tout de suite à l'envolé de grégoryi
l'un des moments les plus forts de
chaque si on parlait sport alors de quoi
allez-vous nous parler Grégory je crois
que vous allez nous parler d'amour
d'amour et entre le parinis et le
département des ivelines on peut le dire
c'est du sérieux car dans un mariage on
dit souvent que le cap des 7 ans est une
étape clé et bien la Course au Soleil et
la collectivité sont sont allé bien
au-delà car pour cette édition 2024 ce
sera une 15e 15e fois d'affilé que le
grand départ de la compétition se fera
depuis le territoire les Yvelines et
parenis c'est une grande histoire
d'amour qui dure alors l'idil a mis un
peu de temps à démarrer il faut le dire
car depuis la création de l'épreuve en
1933 et jusqu'en 2010 aucune commune des
zvelines n'avait accueilli le départ de
la course au soleil il y a bien eu des
villes en scè et Marne dans les hautes
scènes et même en scène Saint-Denis mais
pas dans le 60 18 tout change en 2010
une convention est signée un partenariat
liit désormais ASO et le département
pour les quatre prochaines année c'est
d'ailleurs officialisé ici même au
conseil départemental des iblin le
président du conseil général alors parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelé
autrefois était alin schmidz Christian
prudom vous vous étiez déjà présent en
2010 pour annoncer ce mariage et vous
louyez alors le prestige apporté par le
département des Yvelines à la course
avec ces territoires magnifiques une
idée entité vélo aussi assumé he
puisqu'on rappelle dans ce département
des ivelines il y a plus de 3500
licenciés vélo la première ville
ivelinoise à accueillir le départ du
Parini c'est donc Montfort laamorie nous
sommes le 7 mars 2010 et le prologue
voit la victoire du néerlandais larsbom
le lendemain la première étape s lance
de saint-arnaau en Yveline direction
contre dans le Loir etcher depuis on
peut le dire c'est un peu le coup de
foudre la convention est renouvelée tous
les 4 ans et dernière signature en date
en 2021 qui garantit le départ du Parini
jusqu'au moins l'édition 2025 dans les
Yvelines en mars dernier c'est la
verrière et bazinville qui sont devenus
les 24e et 25e communes du département à
devenir ville départ de la course au
soleil et avec les Murau et toiri en
2024 nous serons donc désormais à 27
villes alors particularité le parinis
n'est jamais parti de Versailles où nous
enregistrons cette émission aujourd'hui
alors j'ai fait mes petits calculs
Michel Christian François nous avons 259
communes dans le département les
possibilités sont donc immenses à raison
de deux communes par édition c'est la
tradition depuis 2010 alors j'ai calculé
que le Paris Nice pourrait partir des
Yvelines jusqu'à l'édition
226 grgor a très bien travaillé ce par
je suis pas sûr que le président du
conseil départemental pierre bélier qui
aime le vélo qui aime parinis qui aime
le tour puisse signer aussi longtemps en
tout cas je seraai pas là pour voir
François non plus puisque nous avons 9
jours d'écart tous les deux mais je lui
dois
donc donc pendant 100 ans c'est pas
possible en tout cas ce que je peux
simplement vous dire ce que nous pouvons
vous dire c'est que on est vraiment très
très heureux de ce partenariat c'est que
le grand départ dans lesines a donné une
force au premier jour de parénis que
l'épreuve n'avait pas forcément avant on
est sorti du du S Ternel contre la
montre systématique le premier jour pour
avoir une étape en boucle qui est le
plus souvent halante voir un premier
jour parfois un courur arrivé seul
parfois deux courur arrivé souvenez-vous
de l'arrivée magistrale de d'Arnaud
demmar et J Philippe ou les trois Jumbo
ensemble Christophe Laporte qui gagne
avec rogl et wiinger il y a quelques
années parfois une demi-douzaine de
coureurs échappés parfois un Ploton
groupé on on a eu des scénarios des
scénaris absolument formidables c'est
facile d'accès les ivelines pour toutes
les équipes qui viennent de plus loin
des différents pays d'Europe c'est juste
à côté de Paris et on a la force du
patrimoine et en même temps aussi le
monde rural pour aller chercher une
première étape qui joue souvent avec le
vent grâce à des parcours concoctés par
par François par François Le Marchand
avec l'aide de de Yannick talamardon
donc voilà donc nous on est très très
heureux vous avez aussi inventé le
département le village du grand départ
de parinis le village existait sur le
Tour de France il n'existait pas sur
parinis et parfois ça a été compliqué
parce que parfois il y a eu du vent au
départ parfois il a fait très froid
parfois il y a eu de la neige et les
équipes du département étaient toujours
là les équipes des collectivités donc
nous on est très très heureux on
souhaite qu'une seule chose très
honnêtement c'est que ça continue
jusqu'en 2125 si vous le souhait6 226
François Le Marchand comment on fait
pour se renouveler quand on part depuis
15 ans depuis les ivlines mais vous
savez j'ai été courur cycliste j'habite
dans les sonnes juste à côté mes
terrains d'entraînement c'était les
ivelines et la Chevreuse la Val de
Chevreuse donc je connais pas mal de
routes beaucoup de routes et je sais là
où ça fait mal je sais où où les
coureurs peuvent doivent puiser pour
pour pour essayer d'attaquer et et et
donc bah on cherche on cherche on prend
les cartes on est au bureau on a toutes
les cartes de l'île-de-fance notamment
des des ivelines pardon et et donc on
arrive à à trouver des des parcours à
droite à gauche pour faire des bordures
pour faire pour aller chercher des
petites difficultés vous savez la
succession de petites difficultés font
des grandes difficultés
donc à la fin ça fait des belles étapes
et on a le sentiment aussi à chaque fois
que sont construit ses parcours alors
Parini c'est avant tout une épreuve
sportive mais c'est d'associer aussi le
le patrimoine il y a toujours belles
images belles images aériennes du
département des Yvelines là encore on va
pouvoir découvrir le le patrimoine
yvlinois même si on parle d'abord d'une
course sportive ouais mais bon
aujourd'hui le le le les les images télé
et puis le le cyclisme ça ça compte pour
un parce que l'un ne peut pas travailler
sans l'autre et c'est vrai que quand on
regarde le vélo à la télé on on voit ces
belles images on voit ce ce ce beau
patrimoine qui est la France avec le
Tour de France notamment mais mais mais
dans les evelines c'est vrai que depuis
2010 nous sommes dans le département
avant il y avait pas d'étable dans les
Yvelines ça n'existait pas et et
aujourd'hui les gens découvrent les
Yvelines grâce au cyclisme et je pense
que c'est c'est c'est pas mal oui
Christian il y a beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui regardent ce parénis
juste pour les images si je peux dire
bien évidemment mais il y a il y a une
vraie fierté à découvrir ou redécouvrir
sa ville son village son département
d'en haut he la prise de vue dominante
des cours cyclistes de parinis du Tour
de France c'est la prise de vue par
hélicoptère donc il y a cette fierté qui
est un élément capital dans la vie dans
la vie d'aujourd'hui et puis en effet
vous avez parfaitement raison c'estàd
que la beauté du parcours les lieux le
patrimoine c'est un élément important du
tracé ça compte et ça participe
justement à cette fiertél donc euh vous
pouvez regarder une course cycliste en
fait les épreuves cyclistes sont les
seules épreuves sportives qui
s'adressent aussi à des gens qui
n'aiment pas forcément le sport et et
c'est pas un handicap c'est un atout
énorme surtout euh en France le premier
pays touristique au monde et dans les
evvelines proximité encore une fois de
Paris euh facilité d'accès et où on a
tout on a tout on on a la ville on a le
monde rural on a des choses
exceptionnelles et on peut aussi parce
que c'est important pour nous également
pratiquer la bicyclette le vélo des
champions sur parenis sur le Tour de
France et puis la bicyclette du
quotidien ou du weekend avec des
terrains d'expression absolument
formidable avec évidemment un
département qui sera en première ligne
qui portera le maillot jaune des
épreuves cyclistes pour les jeux de
Paris François learchand on va revenir
sur cette première étape qui partira
depuis les Les Mureaux le dimanche 3
mars est-ce qu' vous pouvez parler un
petit peu de cette étape elle sera
comment bien elle sera fidèle à ses
habitudes c'est-à-dire euh des
difficultés du vent de la Plaine des des
moments de repos et et surtout on fait
deux boucles parce que c'est important
de faire de boucles notamment pour les
coureurs ça leur permet de voir déjà la
ligne d'arrivée et et ça fait monter un
petit peu le le le public en puissance
157 km 157 km une première boule de de
100 km et une deuxème d'un peu plus de
50 km donc c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on
fait habituellement et c'est ce qui
fonctionne habituellement et c'est ce
qui fonctionnera en 2024 la plus grosse
difficulté peut-être sur cette première
étape la côte d'Herbeville pas loin de
loin de l'arrivée il y aura juste un un
sprint bonification juste avant qui qui
sera très important vous savez qu'il n'y
a qu'un sprint bonification par étape 6
secondes 4 secondes et et 2 secondes et
quand on voit on a vu tout à l'heure sur
les images télé l'attaque de pogachar au
sommet des 17 tournants l'an passé à à
moins de 5 km de l'arrivée pour aller
chercher ces bonifications donc c'est
bien dosé il y a du sel il y a du poivre
le menu est parfait et le lendemain
départ depuis toiri là ça sera du du
plat du plat oui mais le plat dans le
vélo c'est voilà si c'est ouais le plat
c'est bien mais quand il y a du vent
c'est moins bien donc là on va essayer
de jouer avec le vent les coureurs
justement on va en parler les coureurs
ils en pensent quoi de de ce départ
depuis les iblines chaque année ils sont
ravis il y a une première étape et et
nous organisateurs et et surtout les
fans de vélo sont ravis parce que vous
avez une étape sportivement probante dès
le
début et alors le contrôle à montre
c'est l'épreuve de vérité comme on dit
c'est quelque chose de très important
bien évidemment mais c'est chaque courur
l'un après l'autre et nous on veut voir
les champions de parinis du Tour de
France épaule contre épaule dès le début
voilà parce que et et avec le le la
découverte qui est plus importante sur
une épreuve en ligne que sur un contrô à
montre quand vous dites un président de
département re propose 8 km de contre la
montre ou 160 km de course en général la
réponse est assez évidente c'est
d'essayer de montrer le le le territoire
comme on dit aujourd'hui en tout cas le
département donc nous on est vraiment
très très heureux et encore une fois
2126 à François à moi ça nous va bien
et il y a le parignis il y a le Tour de
France pour ao vous avez une expérience
civelinoise si je puis dire en terme de
cyclisme dans leses vous parliez tout à
l'heure des Jeux Olympiques et
paralmpique de de Paris 2024 quand vous
voyez que il y a les épreuves de
cyclisme sur PIST de VTT de BMX cyclisme
sur route aussi qui passera par les
ivelines vous n'êtes pas surpris
j'imagine mais non parce qu'il y a tout
ce qu'il faut et et c'était évidemment
tout sauf un hasard si avec Pierre
Bédier on a souhaité que la la dernière
étape du Tour de France l'été dernier s
lance évidemment de Saint-Quentin et du
véome National euh où on espère récolter
beaucoup de médailles côté français mais
oui le VTT le BMX la route et cetera
pour une grande partie du du du parcours
c'est dans ce département-là encore une
fois la proximité de Paris et toutes les
installations et tout ce qu'il faut pour
avoir des des courses magnifiques euh
depuis 2010 les éines ont vu passer de
nombreux grands noms du cyclisme grâce à
ce parénis grégoryi vous confirmez oui
car c'est la première grande course à
étape du circuit européen parce que la
Course au Soleil est souvent présente
comme une répétition générale du Tour de
France qui a lieu 3 à 4 mois plus tard
alors pour le constater pas besoin de
remonter bien loin juste à l'édition de
cette année donc la précédente édition
pour se rendre compte qu'on a été
chanceux du côté de la verrière et de
bazinville pour la première fois depuis
33 ans les les deux derniers vainqueurs
du Tour de France le sloven TADE
pogachar et le Danois Yonas vingegord
était au départ pogachar vingegord
c'était aussi le dernier grand duel du
Tour de France 2022 qui avait tourn est
en la faveur de vingegord et sur parenis
en mars dernier pogacha rentille patron
remporte pour la première fois cette
course devant David godu 2e à 53
secondes et vingegord justement 3e à 1
minute et 39 secondes mais ce qui se
passe entre les ivelines et Nice n'est
pas forcément gage de vérité puisque le
Danois gagnera bien un 2uxème tour de
France d'affilé quelques mois plus tard
face au slovè la course au soleil peut
être en tout cas un C donner quelques
indications souvenez-vous lors de
l'édition 2022 qui était partie de
mantelaville remporté par primos roglich
l'équipe Jumbo visma avait impressionné
trois victoires d'étape avec Christophe
Laporte vunvonart et primos roglich un
maillot jaune qui a été conservé du
début jusqu'à la fin de l'épreuve c'est
cette même force collective qui avait
été l'une des clés du succès quelques
mois plus tard le premier succès de
Jonas vingegord sur le Tour de France
2022 il n'est pas rare non plus de voir
le vainqueur du parinis s'imposer
également sur la Grande Boucle la même
année depuis 2010 et le parinis dans les
iivlines c'est même arrivé à trois
reprises l'Espagnol Alberto Contador en
2010 même si son titre lui a été retiré
par la suite le Britannique également
bradle Wiggins en 2012 et le Colombien
hegan Bernal c'était en
2017 2015 j'ai un doute 2015 je crois
2015 il me semble et dans la série
récente des vainqueurs du parinis et de
la Grande Boucle on peut ajouter un
autre grand nom guerent Thomas le
Gallois a trusté l'édition 2016 de la
course au soleil avec seulement 4
secondes d'avance sur Contador on dit
aussi souvent que les parinis se jouent
dans un mouchoir de poste de poche
pardon avant de s'adjuger le Tour de
France pour Garen Thomas en 2018 parinis
c'est aussi l'occasion de voir débuter
des pépites dans les rues de Montfort
laamoris en 2010 un slovaque de 20 ans
fait forte impression Peter Sagane pour
sa première grande course chez les pros
il terminera 5e du prologue et et
collectionnera même deux victoires
d'étape la carrière du futur triple
champion du monde sur route et donc
lancé 7 ans plus tard à bois d'arci un
jeune coureur français de 25 ans va
connaître ses premières joies sur une
grande course c'est bien sûr Julien à la
Philippe ce sera lors de la 4e étape du
parisce au montbrouilli à la Philippe
gagne alors son premier contre la montre
individuelle depuis son arrivée sur le
circuit professionnel et c'est vrai j'en
terminerai par là que quand les frenchy
brillent à Dom ile on de boude on ne
boude pas notre plaisir les ivelinois
ont pu voir des athlètes tricolor
revêtir le maillot jaune après le
prologue ou après la première étape en
2013 il s'agit de Damien Godin àou
inasserboig en 2014 à Manent la jolie
Arnaud desmar deux fois en 2017 à
boisery et à Chatou en 2018 enfin on en
parlait tout à l'heure Christophe
Laporte avait remporté la première étape
à montelaville en 2022 bref on peut
espérer pour la prochaine édition 2024
avoir de nouveau un beau plateau pour
cette 82e édition rendez-vous en mars
prochain au Murau et à toiris Christian
prudom pourquoi les stars viennent sur
Paris Nice à votre avis parce que ce
sont les trois coups de la saison qui
sonnent la première grande course par
étape en Europe parce que en mars on est
déjà d'une certaine manière en juillet
parce qu'ils veulent s'étalonner par
rapport à la concurrence et aussi par
rapport à un parcours François Le
Marchand fait en sorte chaque année dès
que c'est possible qu'il y a un lien
entre le parcours de parenis et le
parcours du Tour de France et c'est
évidemment en encore plus fort ce sera
encore plus fort en 2024 puisque le Tour
de France se terminera à Nice et qu'il y
a une soixantaine de kilomètres en
commun à la fois sur la dernière grande
étape de montagne le samedi veille de
l'arrivée finale du tour le 20 juillet
et puis sur le contrôle à monondre que
nous espérons tous décisif évidemment
entre Monaco et Nice le 21 juillet
François learchand qu'est-ce qui les
attire à votre avis votre parcours votre
coup de crayon si je peux dire pour
dessiner ce parcours vous savez le le
niveau des
coureurs renomé bien sûr mais le niveau
des coureurs c'est s'est élevé
considérablement
et il faut qu'on propose des des choses
nouvelles sur parinis à chaque fois des
choses qui n'existaient pas avant on a
la chance dans l'arrière pays ni soit de
pouvoir remonter en altitude à 1200 1500
VO 1600 m sans sans avoir la neige enfin
j'espère et donc ça nous permet de
d'avoir des beau des beaux profils des
beau reliefs et c'est pour ça que les
coureurs aussi viennent je parlais d'un
plat tout à l'heure quand le plat est
bon le courur il arrive nous aussi
d'ailleurs Christian prud est-ce que
vous avez déjà des noms à nous présenter
aujourd'hui non parce que nous sommes le
12 décembre donc la conférence de presse
a lieu 3 semaines plutôt qu'à
l'ordinaire euh en raison des vacances
qui sont un peu plus tardives mais mais
nous ne sommes pas inquiets François
n'est pas inquiet je crois que on va
passer de bonne nuit jusque- là un
certain nombre de grands coureurs comme
chaque année on laissait entendre qu'il
seraiit là et et on aura assurément un
très beau plateau qui préfigurera aussi
à l'évidence celui du Tour de France
notamment pour une une pépite belge qui
devrait faire ses débuts et sur la
Course au Soleil et sur le Tour de
France un TED pogachar Yonas wiingergard
c'est possible on peut pas l'annoncer
non on ne peut pas l'annoncer
euh parce que c'est trop tôt tout
simplement avec les équipes sont encore
en train de faire leur parcours mais on
sait que des coureurs comme vingard
précisément aime courir en France oui
c'est incroyable sur la dernière édition
d'avoir les les deux derniers vainqueurs
du Tour de France je lu disais c'était
la première fois que ça arrivait en 33
ans oui c'était bien et surtout avec les
indications que cela donne parce que
vous avez à l'évidence des indications
mais vous n'avez pas la réponse finale
alors corit donné tada pogachar sur le
Tour de France s'il n'avait pas chuté à
Liège baston Liège après son début de
saison Tony Truant il est revenu après
sa fracture du poignet presque à marche
forcée pour être là on le voyait parfois
moins à l'aise qu'à l'ordinaire
notamment dans les descentes de col il a
dû puiser davantage d'énergie pour
revenir voilà mais en en revanche on a
de vrais de vraies indications vous le
disiez très bien tout à
l'heure tous les coururs qui ont pu
gagner Parini c'est le tour
de Bernal et ca Thomas même si c'était
pas la même année ces dernières
annéesins Contador tous les autres
évidemment mer jacautrefis et puis ceux
qui brillent et qui se qui arrivent au f
un moment d'un seul coup comme Petter
Sagan effectivement à 20 ans il avait à
peine 20 ans peut-être même pas
d'ailleurs il gagne deux étapes on se
dit qu'est-ce que c'est que ce gars là
d'où il sort et puis il fait une
carrière magnifique il est tro fois
champion du monde et cette fois ma vert
du Tour de France il gagne plein
d'étapes TV a l'habitude de suivre cette
tradition conférence de presse ici à
l'hôtel du du département je dois vous
avouer que j'ai l'impression que depuis
un depuis l'année dernière ça monte en
puissance on a l'impression qu'il y a
encore plus d'excitation que d'habitude
ça nous fait ça nous fait très plaisir à
François et à moi c'est c'est c'est une
course magnifique mais vous savez ce qui
fait aussi plaisir c'est c'est de voir
la présence de joseette lolot qui a
dirigé cette course François a travaillé
d'ailleurs pour elle Jean-Michel lolot
son frère c'était c'était le premier
patron des sport auquel j'ai osé envoyer
un CV il y y a 40 ans quand je sortais
l'école de Jourist de Lille il m'avait
très gentiment répondu donc et il a
disparu cet été c'était le la voix de
mon enfance à la télévision donc ce sont
des choses qui comptent les racines il
faut il faut regarder vers l'avenir pour
se développer mais il faut pas oublier
ses racines ça c'est important quand on
est quand on est dans les ivelines et
François le dis sont passés de coururs
professionnel la vallée de Chevreuse
c'est évidemment Jacques angtil c'est
fort ça veut dire quelque chose on a les
racine on a la beauté des paysages on a
le terrain sportivement probant sélectif
donc c'est ça qu'on vient chercher et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une sorte de de
lien naturel entre le département et
nous avec aussi c'est très important ce
lien entre le vélo des Champions et la
bicyclette du du quotidien parce qu'il y
a plein de cyclos qui vont rouler en
Vallé de Chevreuse et le développement
de la bicyclette ce sont les champions
et les championnes qui font que vous
venez que vous êtes intéressés par une
discipline et plein de gens n'ont pas
l'ambition d'être des champions des
championnes mais en revanche ben ça peut
les inciter à faire du vélo quand
j'étais gamin avec Jean-Michel lolot au
commentaire et dit merce qu' allait
gagneré le Tour de France ben avec mon
frère après la retransmission noir et
blanc qu'est-ce qu'on faisait on faisait
le tour du Patier de maison à
vélo dernière question pour tous les
deux si vous deviez retenir un moment de
ces 15 années passées ici dans les
ibines un moment qui vous a marqué ça
sera le le mot de la fin pour pour vous
deux le moment c'est l'arrivée à
boisarcy où c'était très très difficile
pour les coureurs et
vous en souvenez 2000 merci Christian
2017 2017 2017 avec Julien la Philippe
dans des conditions dentesque alors
c'est vrai qu' on préfère le soleil mais
les courses sont belles aussi
malheureusement pour les coureurs mais
quand le temps est exécrable et là ce
jour-là il faisait pas beau et on a une
course magique parfaite voilà c'est
c'est un de mes meilleurs moments de sur
parinis Christian Prom je me doutais de
la réponse qu'allait faire François j'ai
exactement la même c'est vrai que quand
vous avez deux champions et en
l'occurrence de champions français en
problématique bah c'est juste formidable
et quand on voit ce qu'ils sont devenus
suite ce qu'ils étaient déjà mais sils
sont devenus Julien notamment qui a
concrétisé avec ses deux titres de
champion du monde c'est ses jours en
jaune sur le Tour de France ses
victoires d'étapes un peu partout ça son
sourire sa simplicité sa gentillesse son
respect des gens du bord de la route
voilà et et ça on l'a vu de manière très
forte sur parinis c'était un temps
apocalyptique les coureurs parce que je
le dis d'autant plus facilement que mon
palmarès cycliste c'est une feuille de
papier à cigarette les champions
cyclistes les coureurs cyclistes
professionnels sont des gens qui ont un
énorme courage et beaucoup d'humilité à
à l'image de François qui est avec nous
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à à cette émission on vous souhaite bon
courage parce que je pense qu'il va
avoir quelques petits réglag à faire
d'ici d'ici ce parénis 2024 on a encore
le temps François Le Marchand le
confirme Merci à VOUS Grégory canalé
merci à vous pour vos expertises très
précis comme à chaque fois Merci à VOUS
he je l'ai dit en début d'émission vous
êtes une encyclopédie sur le parénis et
vous avez riamment voilà je je vous ai
je vous ai peut-être flatté mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai alors on va terminer
ceci on parler sport par une citation
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
on va prendre une citation de Bernard
Ino 5 fois vainqueur du Tour de France
dans le vélo il y a ceux qui font les
cons et ceux qui ne font pas les cons
moi avec la force que j'avais je pouvais
faire partie de la 2e catégorie je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Co